Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are...
FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us for our eighth episode!
Eighth!
It's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please make sure to tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Thank you!
Today!
We reached 500,000 Ruffians on Youtube!
Thank you!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Thank you so much for all your support.
Ruffians, we couldn't have made it this far without you here.
We wanted to get a little bit closer, but it's a very special moment today.
Thank you.
But we wanted to say a big thank you for all your support.
And, you know, we couldn't have made it this far, you know, to have 1 million subscribers without your love and enthusiasm.
Yes!
So much happy BAU BAUs.
We've really, really, really been touched and even a bit overwhelmed at times by all your heartfelt messages and comments that we've received from you.
Yeah, we're really, really happy.
You know, even though there has been some hard times here and there, it's mostly of our own doing though.
But you know, the fun times far outweigh them.
We know that you'll be always here.
Right?
Supporting us a thousand percent, right?
Right!
It's been really fun.
And all you Ruffians, you mean so much to us.
You know, I think, you know,
We know that we mean a lot to you too, right?
Maybe, right?
But, you know, like, especially when you're maybe going through some hard times, just for us, thinking that even just by a little tiny bit that we're able to protect your smile when it needs protecting the most, it makes us feel really happy and really lucky to be able to do that.
Yeah.
We feel sort of like we found our life's calling.
Like we're home.
Yeah.
Thank you, Ruffians.
Thank you for giving us the job, the opportunity to do so.
We're really thankful to have you here with us.
And of course, you know, we're really happy to have reached this halfway point.
The halfway point of a very big goal.
But to be honest, too, even though it's a big goal, we really didn't think we'd be able to reach halfway like this already!
Right?
It's important to have big goals like we do, but we also understand that they don't always come true.
No matter how hard you work sometimes, you know?
I think, you know, we're really big gamers, but we're also more on the pessimistic side of things recently.
You know, we don't really want to get carried away and make ourselves disappointed when maybe things don't work out.
I feel like that's a thing we do often.
Try not to get too excited, you know?
Because we get excited easily.
Whenever we get ahead of ourselves.
So we don't want to get disappointed.
But thank you, Ruffians.
Thank you for showing us that it's okay to dream big.
And that maybe we don't need to be so pessimistic.
Right?
We want to be able to reach the 1 million goal, right?
But we want to prove ourselves through our hard work too.
So the next 500,000 Ruffians, let's get there with hard work.
And lots of smiles too.
Of course.
Most importantly, we really hope to spend many, many, many more days filled with laughter and happiness together with you.
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Has it been fun so far?
We're just about at three weeks now.
It's been really fun for us.
Yes!
BAU BAU!
Let's continue to work hard, okay?
Yeah, we need you here with us, okay?
Is that okay?
If you're here with us...
Yes!
BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians!
But we'll also have a proper celebration all together soon, so let's have a Rock n' Rawr party then.
Or maybe even a bigger party?
A bigger party!
Thank you, Ruffian!
In the meantime, let's continue to have lots of fun with FUWAMOCO Morning today!
Thank you!
We got some more information from Ruffian!
There's been another Pero Sighting.
Where's Pero this time?
The report says that Pero has been transported into the back room.
Ruffians, do you know much about this place?
The back room.
It looks like an office.
Yeah, just like an office space.
Is it an empty apartment?
Maybe Pero moved in here.
Maybe it's just not furnished yet.
He's still trying to figure that part out, maybe?
He can't move on his own, you know?
Is that the name of the apartment building in the backrooms?
You know, sometimes they're called like... Fancy things, right?
Yeah, you know.
That kind of sounds like... The backrooms.
It's just like a fancy apartment building.
It does kind of look a bit typical.
Not so fancy, but...
You know, so like, I feel like maybe he just doesn't have the sort of luxury, you know?
True.
But out of all the places we've seen Pero at so far, I feel like this is like the easiest, you know?
It's not on the roof of a cool mall or in the hands of a wizard.
Right?
So maybe we can bring him back if we go there.
What do you think, Ruffians?
Should we try to find him?
Do you think we can?
You know, hopefully.
We can, and then... Save him!
No.
Why not?
Go save him.
Do you not care about Pero enough?
We're trying to get sightings so we can go get him, you know?
Yeah, I feel like this is our best chance so far.
Well, hopefully we can find him soon, but just in case we don't, please let us know if you have any more sightings, okay, Ruffians?
Remember, use the hashtag FWMCMORNING, okay?
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians.
There's been a bit of a misunderstanding.
This time, it's pretty awful.
Pretty awful, I think.
Pretty grave.
This happened during our holoCure stream the other day.
You know, certain events occurred... I need to clear my name, okay?
Don't understand.
Okay!
Misunderstand.
You are misunderstanding because you don't understand.
Okay.
I am not addicted to gacha, okay?
You know, in fact, I'm not even the biggest fan of gacha games.
It may seem like I've... Hey, no.
No doubt.
It may seem like I really wanted to spin for the gacha often, because I did, but all I wanted to do was unlock Ola-senpai as a playable character.
You know, freedom from the digital version of the show, right?
I kind of feel bad for them, you gotta respect the senpai.
Exactly.
You know it.
I like farming coins.
And I like unlocking stuff.
But does that mean that I'm addicted to gacha?
It doesn't!
No!
Believe, not doubt.
You know, I feel like the real game with gacha games, even, is to try to play and not spend that much money, you know?
You can be an exemplary free-to-play user, okay?
Yeah, free-to-play user.
That's all!
I just needed you to understand, okay?
I'm not addicted to anything except cute girls and cute cats, okay?
If it's cute girls and cute cats, then... Wait!
What if there's a gacha game that's like cute girls and cute cats?
Not addicted to things.
Okay!
Ruffians, you understand?
You understand?
No misunderstanding!
It's good!
No!
No doubting!
You believe the words coming out of my mouth, right?
Ruffians, let's make sure not to get too carried away like Mocco-chan did there, okay?
Understand?
Good Ruffian.
Sure, sure.
You know, Mocco-chan smiling, I think it's all cleared up now.
Clear.
Mocco-chan.
Mococo is always right.
Yes.
You had another dream, right?
I did.
I did talk about it a bit.
Today we got halfway to one big dream.
But this was a sleeping dream.
My dream.
You haven't told me yet.
I haven't told you, but... I did talk about it, but then I remembered that...
It was a bit embarrassing.
What?!
I should've said nothing!
Oh no, Moco-chan.
I should've said nothing.
Oh no!
Don't be nervous!
I'm nervous enough!
If you're nervous, don't make me nervous!
Okay, so, the other night, I had a dream that left me feeling like really refreshed in the morning.
So it was a good dream!
Oh, it's a good dream!
The best dream!
It wasn't very long, but it was sort of like, something like...
I don't know, it's a bit embarrassing.
I'm only gonna say it once, okay?
Okay.
Don't be nervous!
So, I was in an empty library.
And I saw a Ruffian working on some sort of school project on a computer.
So... An empty library?
It wasn't that!
I don't know if it was empty!
Was anybody else there?
Could you see the dogs?
There was other people.
I think there was other people.
I don't know.
They weren't alone.
I wasn't alone.
And it looked like they were struggling with it.
So then, I went over to help!
I think it was like an English people or something like that.
So then, I pulled up a chair, and I worked on it with them.
And then, until it was all done.
And then they were really happy!
And then I said, bye bye.
And went to leave.
What?
That's it?
What
It wasn't... What happened?
What happened?
You don't... That wasn't you!
What?
Why is there an eggplant in this?
Because there is!
Dudes have eggplants in them.
Dudes have eagles.
So that's how it is!
BAU BAU BYUL.
Ruffians, have you been suffering?
Suffering some weird symptoms?
Maybe you've been feeling a bit funny too.
Maybe it's BAU BAU BYUL.
Well, to explain a bit about BAU BAU, you know, it seems that it's brand new, but it's been recently discovered maybe sometime around the beginning of this month.
There's still a lot that's unknown about it, but at least the early stages of it shows, you know, that
People start to be affected to colors.
Colors!
Colors.
That's just the start.
It gets worse.
But let me explain.
You know, sometimes you see something that's blue and something that's pink and then right away two dogs come into your mind and you can't think of anything else.
That's the warning sign, okay?
You know, and you start to feel a bit of a familiarity, a warmsness.
Just because you see those two colors together, maybe you feel like a little bit happy too.
You understand, you felt that, you felt that, you had that.
Oh my gosh, it's good that you're here right now.
It's a warning sign, okay.
Yeah.
But then... That's just the beginning, you know?
Sometimes, you can even also start to feel an intense pain in your stomach.
Yeah.
While laughing uncontrollably.
And your cheeks hurt because you can no longer control your facial muscles.
You know, you're just smiling constantly and you lose control.
You have no control anymore.
Yeah.
Oh no, your tummy hurts!
Watch out!
Why don't you have it?
Well, later reports, they show that, you know, as it progresses, some Ruffians start BAU BAUing during inappropriate situations and places and time.
You know, sometimes at other dogs and cats, sometimes at other friends, family too, maybe teachers or workplace bosses, even at police officers and firefighters.
No, right.
Ruffians.
Not you, right?
You okay, right?
Is it contagious?
I'm not sure!
We don't know!
It's still new.
We're doomed!
Have you been suffering?
Are you suffering?
What are we gonna do, Moco-chan?
This isn't good!
Do you need a cure, Ruffians?
You need treatment!
Treatment?
We'll have to ask the scientists.
An absolute win!
Oh, wait.
Can we howl?
Is it good, then?
Is it good?
No cure for you, you're done!
Well, you know... I know you're fine.
But if that's the case, you know... I guess the BAU BAUing part might be a bit embarrassing, but... Try to control the symptoms, okay?
Ruffians aren't really suffering.
We don't know the cure yet, but let's try to find something.
If you're happy and smiling, then...
Maybe it's okay?
But if you hurt because of it, then it's no good.
It's a very complicated new disease.
We'll have to find out more!
Ruffians, let us know how you're doing, okay?
BAU BAU BYOU can be serious.
Don't suffer on your own, okay?
Let somebody know.
Today...
We're gonna go back to our regular corner.
We have our Doggie of the Day.
Who's the doggy today?
It's Monja!
Monja is the Doggie of the Day.
She's a little bit on the upside of the ears, but I think
You know, we can all kind of see, but she loves to see just as much as any other puppy.
Young at heart.
Yeah.
Apparently, she's not the best guard dog since she probably just cuddle with the bad guys, but I kind of understand that a bit, right, Moco-chan?
We've gotten better though, right?
Sometimes the bad guys are just scary, so then... It's useless.
Yeah.
But you know, she's looking pretty right here.
She just had a bunch of fun!
What do you think?
Do you think Don-chan smells like a wet dog?
Moco-chan.
Yeah.
I kinda think that... Don-chan, she smells like a good wet dog though.
Maybe more like a marshmallow.
Like a toasted marshmallow wet dog.
Like a cinnamon smell.
You know, cinnamon and butter.
How does Monja, how does she BAU BAU?
I think you'd be somewhat reserved.
Do you think that she swallows seawater sometimes?
What does it sound like?
I think she does, because it's fun.
Just for the heck of it.
What does it sound like, Moco-chan?
Like that!
FUWAMOCO-chan!
What are we gonna be?
Occha!
Very good!
Very good.
I think she's the definition of a sweetie, right?
A very lovely girl.
Yeah, yeah.
Never mean.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Next!
Today!
I went on a walk.
What kind of walk did we go on today?
De-den!
Sunset!
That's a beautiful sunset.
Nice.
We're so happy that you went out.
You had a nice time with your mom too.
Yes!
We're sure that she was really happy to have that time together with you.
Good memories.
And you had cheese corn!
I hope it was yummy.
What is cheese corn like?
Like cheese popcorn!
Like a cheesy coin.
I'm curious!
I hope it was yummy!
I think the world is definitely rewarding you with that sunset too.
You know, just a beautiful sunset to the end of a beautiful day is perfect.
I'm so happy!
I feel so happy!
Thank you, thank you for sharing your warmth with us.
BAU BAU!
Do you two ever have trouble falling or staying asleep?
What do you do when you have sleep problems?
Tweeting this at 1.30am.
I get it.
Ah, we... Sometimes too.
I'm a really heavy sleeper usually.
You know it.
But we sleep different.
I don't know.
You're half heavy sleeper, half light sleeper.
Yeah.
Because sometimes, if you're not fully asleep yet, and I just slightly move, then you go, Mococo!
Be quiet!
I'll be, I'm hot, I'm asleep, but why are you yelling at me?
I'm just moving slightly.
Yeah, apparently I can be pretty angry when I try to sleep.
Yes!
She's very angry when she's sleeping.
Very angry.
Sleep is important.
But, yes, sometimes, you know, when we have a hard time falling asleep, you know, usually it's because there's just too many thoughts swirling around inside our head, you know?
We do that thing, too, you know, when you think about all the things that you said to others, like, like our senpai, you know?
Like, the things you say in a day, and we kind of freak ourselves out.
We know it's not good, but... Right?
I'm sure Ruffians, you do that, too, right?
Nobody else is thinking about it, but...
You can't help but worry sort of day, you know?
Oh I said that and maybe that was weird!
Oh yeah that was weird!
Maybe they misunderstood that!
Maybe that should be in the misunderstanding corner!
Right?
Yeah.
But we have strategies too, you know?
We try to stretch before bed, or take like a warm bath.
Yeah.
Drink hot water, just drink hot water is good too.
It's good for you.
We'll try to put on a relaxing music, like hololive music studio songs.
We really like using warm heating beds with eye masks as well.
We have a special light that makes us even more sleepy too.
Moco-chan bought it.
It's the best.
But yes, putting away your phone far away is important too, I think.
You know your sleep is number one, so the phone, it can wait until the morning, you know?
Even if it goes buzz buzz.
They can wait.
Just think about the priorities.
You need to get your sleep right.
I feel like, you know, it's kind of weird, but when we have a hard time falling asleep, generally, we both do.
Yeah.
Like, it's not just like, ah, Moco-chan, I can't sleep.
You know, it's both of us.
Yeah.
I think it's probably because, like, we share, like, the same worries.
Or when we feel a bit off, we generally both feel off.
Yeah.
So during those times, we try to talk to each other and then sort of figure out why we're not feeling quite right.
And then try to get sleep after that.
And sometimes that helps.
Yeah.
Does that help?
The easiest thing to suggest though is the heating bags.
Yeah.
Always good.
Even in summer.
Yeah, even in summer.
Yeah.
Hopefully that can help you fall asleep more.
Sleep is important to Ruffians.
And solid sleep.
Good sleep, too.
Uninterrupted.
Thank you, BAU BAU!
We're also always looking for more submissions for Pero Sightings, for Doggie of the Day, your walks, and of course, questions!
Please don't hesitate to submit yours with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
We'll be waiting.
BAU BAU!
And let's take a look at our next stream.
De-den!
It's time!
We're gonna be playing Apex together with Bijou and Nerissa.
We're gonna form a strong team.
Yeah, yeah.
But, well, it's actually our first time playing all together.
Yeah.
So, I'm not really that sure what to expect from them.
But it's me playing.
Yeah.
It's me playing.
Not Moco-chan.
Trust your Fuwawa.
Yeah.
Because I'm the strongest.
But yeah, Bijou and Nobisu, they've been pretty quiet about their skills.
I kind of feel like it's a bit suspicious, you know?
Like, you're gonna just completely carry them.
Ah, I think that maybe they're like, Oh, well, Fuwawa, she's like, she's really good, right?
But actually, maybe, I'll just kind of stay quiet and surprise her.
I see.
Yeah.
What do you think, Ruffians?
Do you think that they'll be better than me?
I think... Hmm.
Hmm.
Maybe?
No way.
No way?
No way as in like, Fuwawa's the best?
That way.
Yes!
Yeah!
Thank you, Ruffians.
But yeah, you'll have to be there to see just how strong Abyss is at Apex.
Apex.
And... Our schedule!
We don't have much left of the schedule, but we still have lots of fun coming up.
We're gonna be starting out on The Legend of Zelda Ocarina of Time.
Our first Zelda game together with you, Ruffians.
I'm really excited, you know.
But we're just a bit weird, because we're playing it on the N64, right?
So we're going to keep our fingers crossed that the N64 and the game coaches want to cooperate with us.
They've been through a lot.
A lot, a lot, you know?
There's been a lot of fun that they've given us.
Given us, given Mama Puppy.
And left on for hours and hours and hours.
Without being turned off into the hot summer, you know.
It's all in the original hardware, so let's hunt!
It works out!
Just blow on it, it'll be okay!
That's what we'll do if it's problems.
We're really looking forward to it!
We also have more Donkey Kong Country, so let's hope that we can get to more of it.
More than 8% this time.
Let's hope.
BAU BAU!
You know, we're now at the end of another week of FUWAMOCO Morning.
It went so fast!
But now, it's Friday.
It's Friday, and I know there's a fun weekend.
And next week there'll be even more FUWAMOCO Morning to come!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Viewers today.
Pirate!
BAU BAU!
Cody Witton!
Pikomaru!
BAU BAU!
Enish!
Mr. BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
Harlier!
Pekka!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!